foreign
[Music]
review the show where we break down a
year to bring you some of the most
notable moments in TV and film month by
month the 1980s are a treasure chest of
hits that Hollywood keeps going back to
and 1989 is no exception the years
remembered most by fans for giving us
the first modern big screen Batman plus
the year also gave us many television
shows that would become defining series
of the 1990s from the earlier sketches
of The Simpsons and Seinfeld and the
Brilliance of do the right thing join us
as we venture back to the defining
movies and television shows that ended
the 80s teleporting telephone booth not
required
number three
in 1987 filling in on The Late Show for
a fire Joan Rivers Arsenio Hall became
the first black host of a late night
talk show though the hall hosted shows
was a ratings boost he left when his
contract was up saying that he had plans
to do other things other things meant
co-starring opposite his friend Eddie
Murphy in Coming to America and creating
his own talk show with his own name you
are right 500 000.
as long as you ask him why don't we go
for a cool million
you do not think that would be
that would be Paul's loose atmosphere
including audience dog chants and
segments on things that make you go hmm
the nightly series left a lasting mark
on the landscape but it couldn't survive
the Leno Letterman Late Night Feud after
Johnny Carson retired
[Music]
from things that make you go hmm to
things that make you go
following two endearing dimwits who
travel through time to better understand
High School History Bill and Ted would
become a beloved pop culture franchise
for its ability to make you laugh with
its characters instead of at them
strange things or a foot at the Circle K
dudes you guys are gonna go back in time
yeah you are going to have the most
excellent adventure through history
who are you guys were you dude
no way yes way 10 two sequels and an
animated series would follow Excellent
Adventure and though the slacker buddy
comedy would attempt to be replicated
it's safe to say that no other film has
combined Van Halen with Socrates critics
say Keanu Reeves and Alex Winter are
just Charming Goofy and silly enough to
make this fluffy time travel Adventure
work
[Music]
time travel was a theme throughout 1989
which included the inventive Sci-Fi TV
drama Quantum Leap the past experience
tells me we're probably gonna get stuck
with her you know you look like you've
been in a fight with a wild cat if
you're gonna sneak up on me at least you
could have a decency to reflect in the
mirror
Scott Bakula played Dr Beckett a
physicist who leaps into the bodies of
people throughout the history of mankind
to correct historical mistakes simply by
trying to get Beckett back to the time
that he knows from his own experiences
Quantum Leap was able to apply a
narrative structure to individual
Twilight zone-like episodes Quantum Leap
debuted in March 1989 and ran for five
seasons on NBC similar to Bill and Ted
Quantum Leap has remained a popular
cultural reference due to its core
message of trying to instill decency and
kindness to keep from repeating the past
oh boy oh no I told you it's a girl
critics say Quantum leaps fresh and
funny take on science fiction elevates
its simple premise into a Charming piece
of classic television
I wouldn't get my hopes up Lloyd I'm
sorry
it's just you're a really nice guy and
we don't want to see you get hurt
I want to get hurt Lloyd Doppler wants
to feel something at the start of say
anything the aspiring kickboxer and
average student played by John Cusack
has decided to ask out Diane Court the
class valedictorian played by Ione Skye
immediately after graduating Cameron
Crowe's directorial debut hoists up the
rom-com boombox for a new generation
it's set in Seattle just before grunge
takes over but of course still present
in that desire to drop out of society
and rethink what's an acceptable style
and approach to life is this where we
can add that since the setting is in
Seattle and it was released in April say
anything offers A fitting John Cusack
rain scene
in my heart and she gave me a pen
critics say one of the definitive Gen X
movies say anything is equally funny and
heartfelt and it established John Cusack
as an icon for left of center types
everywhere why is it always raining on
sad Cusack
foreign
travel in 1989 pop culture continued via
the most unlikely Source imaginable a
cornfield in Iowa hey
is this heaven
no
it's Iowa
Field of Dreams was a heartwarming drama
for the Heartland it starred Kevin
Costner as a farmer who hears a saying
know what it or who he is but through a
vision he decides that it is a baseball
field in his cornfield eventually the
disgraced Chicago White Sox of 1919
wander out from the stocks and start
playing ball field of dream showcases
the joy and spectacle of Sports at the
most reduced level without money or
Legacy on the line it has built its own
they don't make them like they used to
Legacy however in 2021 a regular season
game between the Yankees and White Sox
was played at the site of the film with
Costner in attendance the game drew the
highest TV ratings of any regular season
game that aired that year critics say
Field of Dreams is sentimental but in
the best way it's a mix of fairy tale
baseball and family togetherness
and
it's humble kneels before God
[Music]
the third Indiana Jones film was a
course reset by Steven Spielberg after
Temple of Doom was met with a more
divisive reaction than Raiders of the
Lost Ark no underground child slavery
camps here instead we get a whip smart
young Indiana Jones played by River
Phoenix to deliver the most positive
message that whatever Indiana Jones
finds belongs in a museum
you got hard kid but that belongs to me
belongs to Coronado's dead and so are
all of his grandchildren this should be
in a museum the Last Crusade repeats the
bad guys of Raiders with evil Nazis
trying to locate a sacred artifact again
but with Spielberg is most interested in
is a son trying to win the respect of
his father which actually makes it a
spiritual companion to Field of Dreams
if you put it in a museum respect will
come that belongs in a museum critics
say lighter and more comedic than its
predecessor Indiana Jones and the Last
Crusade Returns the series to the brisk
serial adventure of Raiders while adding
a dynamic double act between Harrison
Ford and Sean Connery
[Music]
but
he can't make an omelette without
breaking some eggs
[Laughter]
we could devote a museum to all the
different iterations of a big screen
Batman movie that didn't happen but in
1989 a modern take finally made it to
the big screen despite its title Jack
Nicholson contractually received top
billing as Joker opposite Michael
Keaton's Batman director Tim Burton was
attached to the film after the success
of peewee's big adventure but it didn't
receive a studio green light until his
and Keaton's Beetlejuice became a
financial success in 1988. Burton
described his approach to Bringing
Batman Joker and Gotham to life was by
envisioning it all as quote a complete
Duel of the freaks Nicholson's permanent
smile makeup was matched by the Art Deco
designs of Gotham the set design won an
Oscar making Batman the first comic book
movie to win a competitive Oscar Bruce
Wayne's dual Persona of wealthy Playboy
and vigilante enforcer added to the
visual clashes that Burton created
Keaton was concerned that Wayne's
identity as Batman would be too easily
discernible and so he decided to voice
each Persona in different vocal
registers something that every Batman
has done since going to kill you I want
you to do me a favor I want you to tell
all your friends about me what are you
I'm Batman critics say an eerie haunting
spectacle Batman succeeds as dark
entertainment even if Jack Nicholson's
Joker too often overshadows the title
character
wake up wake up wake up wake up up you
wake up you wake up you wake up you wake
do the right thing is one day and night
on a Bed-Stuy Block in Brooklyn like
heat baking into the cement tensions
Rise by the hour between the
African-American community and the
Italian-American Pizzeria that refuses
to put up any black celebrities on its
Wall of Fame Spike Lee's film is
alarmingly accurate on race relations in
America from 1989 to 30 plus years later
from the police who Patrol neighborhoods
to gentrifiers moving in and small
businesses in minority neighborhoods
that don't reflect the demographics of
their patrons
time out
time out y'all take a chill you need to
cool that out Lee explores every aspect
of race but his film remains loose funny
and tender until its shocking conclusion
critics say smart vibrant and Urgent
without being didactic do the right
thing as one of Spike Lee's most fully
realized efforts and one of the most
important films of the 1980s
so you know she called and said she
wants to go out with you tomorrow night
God class W
yeah well not exactly
I mean she said you know she called this
morning said she had to come in for a
seminar and maybe we get together
no no I hate to tell you this you're not
gonna see this one famously called the
show about nothing Seinfeld debuted in
July 1989 and changed television comedy
forever though Jerry Seinfeld had a
wacky neighbor what his show didn't have
was a wacky premise it simply was about
friends who went about their day careers
and love lives and tried to make sense
of it all the observation humor of
reading people's body language or
mundane discussions of button placements
on a shirt dazzled critics starved for
something new and exciting Seinfeld ran
for nine seasons and left a lasting mark
on pop culture the first season mostly
irons out the characters we'd come to
love and shamefully see ourselves in
though the show about nothing became the
catchphrase descriptor Seinfeld and
co-creator Larry David actually pitched
the show as the mundane occurrences in
daily life life that could become
material for a comedian stand-up routine
TV critics Champion Seinfeld in its
early Seasons even as it was slow to
cultivate a substantial audience but by
season 4 Seinfeld cracked the top 30 in
the ratings and the rest is history
including a history-making deal during
which all nine seasons were bought by
Hulu in 2015 for 180 million dollars a
price too rich for everyone else until
Netflix secured the rights in 2021.
critics say Seinfeld's first season lays
out the template for the show's Unique
Style effectively outlining the hugless
lesson free humor that would later make
it an oft imitated classic I was trying
to lead the way
we needed
11 saw two Timeless rom-coms with
ellipses in their titles When Harry Met
Sally shares more in common with say
anything than the dot dot dot after its
title however both films highlight how
friendships with the opposite sex can
make men better equipped to become
thoughtful Partners in Rob Reiner's
comedy written by Nora Ephron that
includes listening to a friend fake and
orgasm in a restaurant to prove a point
on the ease of manipulating fragile male
egos
are you okay
oh
God
oh god
oh the classic scene with the perfect
punch line was suggested to be performed
as is by Meg Ryan to the Delight of
Ephron when the script had become uneven
Ephron suggested Sally discuss faking an
orgasm but it was the star who took it
to the next level saying that she could
do it on the spot at a crowded
restaurant oh
I'll have what she's having positive
um Word of Mouth paid off at the box
office with no fakery critics say Rob
Reiner's touching funny film set a new
standard for romantic comedies and he
was ably abetted by the sharp interplay
between Billy Crystal and Meg Ryan
[Music]
NBC's Saturday morning audience was
losing to the competition when it
attempted a new approach a live-action
comedy filmed in front of a studio
audience to try to take teams away from
Saturday morning cartoons say by the
Bell was a retooled update of a canceled
Disney Channel show good morning Miss
Bliss though Miss Bliss didn't work on
Disney creator Peter Ingle took positive
notice about the student characters and
came to NBC with a show entirely based
around teenagers the teen characters of
Zack Jesse Kelly Screech Lisa and Slater
would become defining for a generation
though the show was as educational and
informative as after school specials it
was The Lovable characters that made the
PSAs go down easy some of which would
become shared punch lines when kids got
older and realize that the big scary
drug episode was about caffeine pills
pills you mean you really are taking
drugs
just seek you can't sing tonight
[Music]
Baywatch another unconventional
television success debuted on NBC in
September 1989. it only lasted one
season however Yes you heard that
correctly no need to rewind while
Baywatch did become the most watched
American Show on Earth it became that
through syndication 1.1 billion people
watched around the world at the height
of its popularity it was star David
Hasselhoff who believed that there was
still potential for the show and he
purchased the rights after cancellation
and sold Baywatch in syndication to
numerous U.S and international markets
Hasselhoff's popularity in Europe due to
his music career helped turn Baywatch
into a worldwide phenomenon that
eventually reached back to the shores of
the USA let's cue a Borat shall we
hacker
CJ
a pleasure to meet you CJ foreign
[Music]
throughout its lengthy run the cast of
beauties rotated around Hasselhoff and
the red swimsuits continued to shrink
while many aligned to mock the show
there is no denying how much the
Lifeguard melodrama dominated pop
culture but while the media Focus was
always on the skimpy attire and used
dismissive terms like babewatch
viewership was actually 65 percent
female a BBC study showed that women
preferred tuning in to see other women
saving lives instead of just being saved
so see Baywatch was important
yeah
October 1989 had eclectic family
offerings atop the box office with the
baby narrated Look Who's Talking
dominating the month's earnings right
behind it was the dialogue free French
film The Bear which followed a bear's
life from Cub to full-size Kodiak but
only one of these film featured a wee
bub hallucinating on mushrooms though
thanks
cute
[Music]
with how dominant Disney Animation has
been from the 90s onward it's hard to
believe that there was ever a lull but
in the 80s Disney found itself with more
animation competitors than ever before
after some successful co-productions
with Steven Spielberg's amblin
entertainment 1989 kicked off what would
become known as the Disney Renaissance
this was where the studio returned to
its roots and applied a musical format
to classic fairy tales and the Little
Mermaid released in November 1989 would
kick off a decade of success from this
approach Disney plucked Howard Ashman
and Alan Menken from the stage to
provide a big new Broadway feel to the
musical numbers The Little Mermaid is
the story of Ariel a mermaid who dreams
of being a human to pursue a land Prince
and makes a deal with Ursula the sea
witch to be with him the big musical
moments are accompanied by her fish and
waterfowl friends
oh yeah
you want something done you've got to do
it yourself
first we got to create the Moon
the result only the highest grossing
animated movie of all time at the time
of release that was 211 million clams
critics say The Little Mermaid ushered
in a new golden era for Disney animation
with warm and Charming hand-drawn
characters and catchy musical sequences
[Music]
thank you I love a glass of that wine
Bart brought us sorry Marge some white
guy stuck a cork in a bottle oh my God
you hear that Marge my boy speaks French
from one Unstoppable animation effort to
another The Simpsons debuted In December
1989 from the nuclear power plant to
Springfield Elementary to the Krusty the
Clown show in Moe's Tavern so many of
the Beloved characters and iconic
locations debuted in the first few
episodes It's currently in its 33rd
season with no end in sight making The
Simpsons by far the longest running
scripted show in history with more than
700 episodes aired it'll be impossible
to cover the show's lore in a brief
sound bite so let's look specifically at
the program's introduction a holiday
special The Simpsons introduced the
principal family of Homer Marge Bart
Lisa and Maggie Simpson threw a very
identifiable family problem feeling the
money crunch as Christmas approaches
first the evil rich bossy Montgomery
Burns denies a bonus then a second job
has added paycheck deductions the only
gift that year becomes a greyhound
kicked off the racetrack for losing too
much and with that the teachable moment
the family Dynamic of laughing off
life's disappointments and overall
unfairness was set for the rest of the
series I don't know much trying is the
first step towards failure
though the running couch gag would start
in episode 2. critics say The Simpsons
first season proves a quickly addictive
introduction to America's animated first
family with a run of entertaining
episodes that set the stage for a
groundbreaking series
dad didn't they invent Christmas tree
lots so people have to drive all the way
out to nowhere and waste all Saturday
they invented them rust because people
forgot how to have a fun old-fashioned
family Christmas and are satisfied with
scrawny dead overpriced trees that have
no special meaning my toes are numb
while Christmas introduced one of the
most beloved television families in
December 1989 it also became the
backdrop for the third Vacation movie
the first two vacation films found the
Griswolds on the highways and skyways
but Christmas Vacation let them stay
home proving that it's not travel that
makes Clark Griswold overreach in his
attempt to give his family perfect
old-fashioned fun it's just Clark
Griswold critics say while Christmas
Vacation may not be the most disciplined
comedy it's got enough laughs and good
cheer to make for a solid seasonal treat
while the critical reception was average
Christmas vacation has become a seasonal
staple and surely has made neighborhood
lighting competition fiercer
oh pluck it's so lovely
is there a home like this to spend
Christmas with 1989 being such a
formative year for new television shows
we had to leave off several popular
movies in the summary in this year we
saw sequels like Lethal Weapon 2 Back to
the Future 2 and new franchises like
Honey I Shrunk the Kids weakened up
Bernies and kickboxer plus critically
acclaimed hits like Driving Miss Daisy
Dead Poet Society Sex Lies and videotape
born on the 4th of July and Drugstore
Cowboy also while we mention many
television shows 1989 was also our
introduction to Doogie Hauser MD and
family matters in the end 1989 gave us
the first successful comic book movie
one of the most important movies of the
decade and a whole catalog of
long-lasting Television Mainstays oh and
Roadhouse we had to fit that glorious
parade of mullet somewhere in here
[Music]
goodbye 1980s